my girl's grandma died and tried to
explain to foreo he's like where'd
grandma go and i don't really believe in
like
you know jesus christ and all this stuff
i'm not catholic or christian i was like
and because my girl's like oh she's in
heaven my son's like what's happening
like is she though
you know it's tough with a four-year-old
man what did you say
d i think dmt that kind of stuff shows
you there's something more i'm sorry
do you go on no go it's over yeah
it's over kid usually you get them a
hamp you get them a little animal or
something to teach them about death well
i did though cause we got a lizard in
the backyard and i said grandma's like
that liz right now
pull out a revolver my grandma's that
lizzer dude yeah my mom she got us two
hamps and uh
named after our grandparents claire and
lady bro and they both died and that's
how she kind of prepared us for whenever
they were gonna die that's smart this
was my life lesson as a kid
i had a hamster right my brother's like
i want a hamster and he got this
dark hamster with red eyes i'm like that
thing seems evil
and then we put them in a cage together
woke up the next morning
my brother's dark evil hamster ripped my
hamster's face off and ate it
i'll tell you that's how i learned about
death and that's life baby yeah that's
my
[ __ ] so curtis oh [ __ ] we had this kid
named bro
yeah that's life lesson [ __ ] together
yeah bro welcome to the real world bro
welcome to this burning target
[ __ ]
let's get your [ __ ] microphone out
now man here's what i'm saying though
man
so dude we stayed at this kid named
curtis's house bruh and we used to have
to sleep all in his bed and we would
sleep body
different ways like head to toe
and uh and in the middle of the night
their dog was barking all night and the
dad went out there and put a bullet
right in his head
oh my god yeah that's dark that's super
dark
and there's my buddy after a dance had a
girl come over the beautiful girl man
and i had a crush on her but it was the
same buddy that i used to
you know just the yeah god man
shout out scott satchel the guy was just
the ladies man dude and
and so uh and he ended up touching this
girl's vagina you know
yeah and uh
curtis's dad came out and smelled his
fingers by the fire oh
over and over again until we all went to
bed oh that dad has a problem huh
i don't know no he does i'm telling him
bro he made him kind of stay out there
and i remember being inside like looking
out the window and he was still out
there smelling it like what's all those
fingers that smells so good you know
did he have some top ramen or something
so yeah it's just different times man
get this dark huh i'm pumped we didn't
even know we were this [ __ ] up huh
you're scared yeah i was like i'm
thinking about when i was seven i had
bought this lizard at the renaissance
fair in philadelphia oh yeah snakey
checks out
this guy he was a spotty gecko and i was
seven and i said how long is this dude
gonna live because i don't wanna have to
see him die before i graduate high
school and he's like he's gonna live
until you're like
old man i was like word because i know
reptiles live that long
so i'm chilling five months later it's
the american idol finale beau bites
versus carrier underwood
i'm a huge bob ice guy oh you're a bob
dude i would vote every time multiple
times in the same photo
i'd use friends phones to vote for beau
biscuits i was more of a clayton guy but
you can see it
nobody was more into bob ice than me
right that night they go carrie
underwood as is the new american idol
i'm [ __ ] sobbing i'm like no
i walk into my room dude snakey is
slumped over
he's dead as [ __ ] and i'm like oh my god
oh my
gosh i thought the story was gonna get
really dark you couldn't handle him
losing he was walking you looked at the
lizard you're like well
no that's bo bice but yeah my mom
so your road trip would be beau baez it
would be all about bites he's still
making music
you see bob is three is that the name of
that album how is that not called both
rice
he was sick though
[Music]
is